okay yeah the next talk is by Matthews
no dusty
margins and Sweeney said I guess okay
thanks for having me
and thanks also for Jason for talking a
lot about margins in fact I've heard a
lot about margins both in this workshop
in the last workshop so all of
everything I'm presenting today is joint
work with Zoo AG and always whenever I
mention him I don't really know how to
introduce him some kind of
co-conspirator or collaborator or friend
or co researcher and today I'll say that
he is my co enthusiast we're very
enthusiastic about margins we we just we
just have like tons little lemmas lying
around and when I was thinking about
what to talk about today you know
apologies for the non informative title
which allowed me to talk about anything
I wanted you know and so in the in the
boot camp we had naughty talk for three
hours about these sorts of questions
Jason just talked for now or syria's
gonna talk so when Zhu and I when we you
know like once a month when we contact
each other and say oh you know so what's
the progress on so how is deep rel it
has max margin proofs for a deep value
going sometimes we just get frustrated
and we say wait why why does margin
maximization even make sense in the
linear case so in the contrast to the
other three talks that talked about
these phenomena my main goal today is
actually very very modest I I hope I can
pull it off which is I want everybody to
leave the room with a very clear
intuition on why margin maximization
happens even in the linear case and let
me explain what I mean by clear
intuition and of course it's astounding
me to pull this off if you know if you
stopped me on the street and you just
say with me not knowing anything about
you you just say why why can I minimize
a convex functions with gradient descent
I'll just say put the marble on the hill
and watch it roll down so hopefully for
today we can we can get the same thing
for margin maximization a very kind of
intuitive explanation for what's going
on and just be clear thank you all so
Misha for accidentally setting up my
second slide so let me just be clear
about the phenomenon I start with some
initialization
in this case orthogonal to the next
margin direction so we can just look at
this I've got plus points minus points
this is the origin max margins that way
so you run gradient descent or whatever
you want on the logistic loss
exponential loss maybe you have
exponential tail and everything today it
goes that way so I hope again from today
everyone will feel very comfortable with
this phenomenon that'll be very
intuitive why this happens to be clear
erm could be anything in a cone of
solutions all of those because your
training area yeah let's revisit it's
here and anyway let's let's come back to
this because um okay so the pop quiz for
me for how will I present this today is
if in 40 minutes you're convinced that
me having to answer your question okay
let's see in 40 minutes okay
so that's the question when I say why so
here's the here's p.m. ya 38 so here's
the so here's the plan for today the
first part I just want to give some
overview of some motivation and
discussion of margins of course we heard
about it so much so for the intuition
I'm gonna give you two intuitions one is
in the primal and one isn't the dual and
then finally I'll give some brief
nonlinear comments kind of by complete
miracle this morning I was debating
paying Jason and asking to see his
slides but somehow magically not only do
we complement each other but actually
somehow exactly the set of things I say
about the nonlinear case it's exactly
complimentary what Jason said so thank
you Jason that went very nicely
okay so first let me tell you about
margins and also complimenting Jason
slides so Jason very kindly gave the
usual introduction to deep learning as
you know solving cancer and famine and
all these things and not costing any
energy in the process so let me give
another motivation for why to study deep
learning which is
you know this alien spaceship appeared
this alien spaceship with this bizarre
technology I don't know why any of this
stuff works and you know we break into
this thing and we start taking things
apart I mean this is exactly how I
studied deep learning I it's like oh is
the following true every time I think
the following is true I run the
experiment I'm wrong every single time
and then I try to prove a theorem
suppose I will say I fail snows like
succeed but for me my approach to be
playing is really like investigating
some bizarre alien technology that just
happened to crash-land into my GPU and
so in this in this philosophy
I view math as a lens and what's kind of
exciting is that and it's been exciting
about this program this summer is is you
know we don't know which math we should
use many people say things like Oh
uniform convergence is busted you know
we can also use physics being use all
just a weird stuff to analyze what's
going on in this alien spaceship and the
lens I'm going to use today is margins
so while I'm still uh well I still have
like those 30 minutes for uh ramesha
so let me just test everybody's beliefs
so here I have the same data okay I have
one data set and I've run three
different SVM's with three different
kernels and obtained three solutions so
these are contours
okay these are contours of the real
light outputs and I want everyone in the
audience to guess what the contours for
the rel you look like so what I'm going
to guess what do you believe the Contras
look like if you want me to say some
things about with apologies I don't
actually remember I think I did depth
two and with roughly order n so so feel
that it's like somewhat in the
parametrize it's gonna get you know it's
someone your primary settings so what
does everyone believe that guess make it
you know commit to a guess for what you
think the contour looks like so I should
say that this is one of the cases that I
was very confident what I thought would
happen and I was wrong this is the
contour I have to say this completely
blew my mind
why so just just look it so first of all
look how smooth and nice this boundary
is no way I read no regularization by
the way
look how smooth and nice the boundary
and especially look that there's no bump
near these data points you know let's
we're like really aggressively
overfitting I would expect this contra
to kind of weave in and out here kind of
like it does for this narrower RBF
kernel SVM I I found this plot utterly
shocking you know if you after you
stopped me in the street and ask me
about marbles and Hills
if you then if you then asked me which
classifier should you use if you're in a
pinch you know nothing about your data
and based on this I'd pick the rail you
network this for me this was shocking oh
it was fully connected yeah yeah to
layer like order n parameters let me
show an let me say that as far as I know
the origin of margins is Novikov 962 for
the perceptron convergence theorem but
of course it's probably earlier
similarly you know there's so many ideas
and so you know around then that are mr.
tributed and things like that probably
know why this was another carrot soup
and a comb over off type thing okay so
let me give you another plot to kind of
motivate margins a little bit better so
the margin here is the usual multi-class
definition of margin I take the output
on the correct label and look at the the
the best output for the in for an
incorrect label and I normalize in this
some way for now ignore the
normalization and what you can do here
is you can make a CDF okay I do this for
the training set and I get a CDF of
these margins and so this is something
that people investigated very heavily
90s for boosting and if you plot this
CDF so again we want this plot it's hard
to see there's a zero here we want all
these numbers be very positive I mean
the margins are good
if you run coordinate descent or
adaboost or whatever you want to call it
then it pushes things to the right see
it's hard to see once again but at this
point zero is scrolled off okay so this
happens with corner descent and boosting
and if you rerun it with you run it with
deep learning and here I've actually
told you what's going on you get the
same kinds of plots okay zero Scrolls
off so what I'm saying is that some
margins are one lens that we're going to
use and it appears that if we run
gradient descent and asks of course
Jason just told us it appears to be
maximizing margin
it's hard to see because where zero is
but the point is that the CDF which
gives the margin distribution is fully
shifting to the right so this means that
gradient descent is I do not tell you
what CF is so not ease point here is
that as s was mentioned by Jason these
are hope I'm using homogeneous neural
net neural Nets here which mean that
constants can just come in and out
possibly with an exponent and so the
scale of this matters law because if I
just only cared about the numerator I
could just multiply everything by
thousand and get the thousand times
better so now let me do some
normalization which thank you very much
naught T is crucial to this question so
if I look at C far with true and random
labels and I do this plot then they're
on top of each other margins are
normalized say nothing about there's
been random and true labels but if you
normalize it in some way then you get
this separation and I don't want to
dwell on this today but I'll just say
that the normalization I use in all
these plots is given by a generalization
bound so you take questions on them if
you want but but the the norm that I use
for the normalization is given by a
generalization bound and this now
separates these things okay and so now
if we plot what not to was asking about
now if we plot the the this margin
distribution over gradient descent
epochs then we see that it starts out
with many incorrect margins and then
slowly tries to ship them all so I
stopped this once everything was past
zero there's a zero this is zero here we
need to send applied to this was
actually for Alex net so gradient
assigned applied to Alex net is
maximizing margins and it is getting a
large margin predictor even after
normalization yeah so you talking about
margin is if it's a one dimensional
property for applauding an infinite
dimension
oh no no no this is a one-dimensional
property the margin is just the out
because it's the range
it's the range I take there it's all
written out here this is the true label
and then this is the maximum over the
incorrect labels so even if it's a K
output thing I get a 1 out this is fully
univariate thing CDF yeah oh I see you
were time yes you're saying what do you
mean by maximizing that guy's and also I
mean I have a generalization bound that
depends on for example sweeping to the
right
you know performing a balance between
how much am I gonna pay in my margin
loss and then how much do I get to
decrease my bottom laughter right but I
could also potentially much more
sophisticated bound depends on the whole
curve yes let me let me rephrase at
least the last part into a question so
it is true that many of the bounds they
have two terms one which is the margin
error or the number of margin violations
and errata more complexity of scales
inversely with the margin and yes if
essentially all these bounds I've ever
seen either are explicitly state or can
be providing mm over those margins in
terms of depending on the entire curve
the distribution I'll return this later
okay so let me clean up what I'm staying
a little bit because I'm already somehow
magically running behind so and it's
absolutely not your fault it's you can
just say it after you ask the question
just when I realized that I'm a you know
it sounded wrong like like Dan why are
you so let me just briefly say the
concrete bound which has the form that
Dan was mentioning you know this bound
has been mentioned many times in you
know
so I'll just I'll just have some
retrospective comments but to be clear
the way the bound looks is you give me
your your row Lipschitz activation needs
to go through 0 at 0 then with probably
1 minus delta over the data you give me
a margin give me the weights then and
and as he was saying I I can make this
not just the maxim Marge and I can I can
fail on a bunch of points okay so the
bound looks like this data times
Lipschitz over the margin times a
penalty for being a nonlinear function
just this part is tight with with a
lower bound it's this part where we pay
for the deep network it goes like this
let me just say briefly in about 20
seconds because I think most people that
mention this bound to mention how it's
proved it's proved to be an induction on
the layers every layer you give yourself
some cover budget at the end you solve
Lagrangian and that's where these funny
exponents come from and I should just
say that when you when you do this
induction you're paying kind of a
worst-case penalty at every layer and
you don't really have a good
coordination across layers people
criticize is bound in various ways I'll
get I'll give you another one so I can
just add dummy nodes all throughout the
network and add you know zero
connections cancellations everywhere
blow everything up function is the same
bound goes to infinity you know say and
then part of this is because it's not
very coordinated and what's going on
inside the network it does this worst
case sort of induction across the layers
so you're some retrospective comments
you know now that it's been a couple you
know in in deep learning time you know
you know multiple ice ages have come and
gone multiple civilizations have
collapsed
the aliens have repopulated us and all
these kinds of things so so I should say
that a margin assumption is a very
complicated assumption on the data you
just think about it for for linear
predictors I can just I can already you
know I can just visualize when an l2
margin means it just got this little gap
around the geometrically saying that
I've got a large margin deeper lu
network like oh my god okay right that's
that's nuts
okay that's that's one comment so i'm
just saying that often when i talk with
with adam here he tells me how am i
circumventing certain hardness results
and how in my plans for optimization
well the margin assumption is very
complicated okay that's one comment
another comment is that as I said
margins you're just Allen's margins are
just one way to study generalization
there many other you can throw that part
out or there many other parts this story
perhaps is not to mention the
normalization this was the normalization
is more important and a harder part of
the story to derive you know there are
many parts this story another thing I
should say is that subsequent work has
adjusted this setting a lot that's how
they get better bounds and I should also
say that justice a purely technical
question I mentioned this to one person
the audience that's a purely technical
question the only known proof of this is
via this technique called matrix
covering no one on earth knows how to
prove this directly via Rademacher
complexity for instance you like peeling
no one knows how to do it
it's the funny funny take a little
comment through anybody who wants to
play with it and part part you know
there are many choke points that cause
this one of them is that in the bound
allows arbitrary multivariate gates
that's how we handled max pooling
there's some random retrospective
comments on this bound there are many
ways to improve the bound and many ways
to refine the class and things like that
so I should say that this so the paper
provided two things one was the
generalization bound which is part two
of this story so it says if you're a
function class or you're for predictors
have certain reasonable properties or if
you call this not reasonable whatever
you want to call it as these properties
are generalizes and it gave empirical
evidence that this happens he gave
empirical evidence in the form of well
it's like this that gradient descent on
deep networks actually does output these
these nice large margin classifiers so
again it had a two-part story an
empirical evidence and a theoretical
component and what I want to talk about
today slated to Jason or most of what
Jason talked about is the optimization
question so I want to prove that
gradient descent gets good max margin
predictors and finally I can get to what
I talked about 20 minutes ago apologies
for that now I want to give you guys the
clean intuition on or a clean into which
and I hope on on why margin maximization
is actually happening so first let me
just say that there's a large history in
this so the perception of proof of
course is a guarantee on on gradient
descent with the Rayleigh loss for
linear functions
assuming margins
and then um this Shapiro named Bartlett
Lee paper gives a positive margin
tongcheng and and Bing you this one
gives max margins in oh five then as
Jason mentioned I got max Marge entered
in then and I'll mention multiple times
as proof by by Daniel surgery sir you
over here naughty and a lot Hoffer and
sorry what's so I mentioned these but
there are three essential techniques and
I'll cover two of them today and Jason
very kindly did the third so one is
controlling thing is in the primal and
vaguely is that these three techniques
work in the primal then there's an
approach using duality and I'll make
some comments about this proof this
proof for me is actually in the primal
and dual I'll talk about that a little
bit apologies for the authors for uh
random things about their proof and then
there's of course the regularization
path approach which is what Jason and
tell me you followed about 20-30 minutes
ago okay so good so that was the margin
setup margins are a thing there one way
that we can analyze this alien
spacecraft okay so let me give give you
what I hope is one intuition on why this
is happening okay so here's the example
again so I just slowly
ghost the you know goes to the I guess
the left for all of you so let me just
establish some notation that I'll use
for both parts maybe I'll I'll write
some of it up here just so that we don't
have to get confused so I'm taking all
my data and I'm putting it in this
matrix
and then I'm defining unregular eyes or
sorry an unknown alized loss just
because I don't want to write n a couple
times so here's my risk where I have it
written 1 over N I'm using the
exponential loss for simplicity and
those of you that you know you can just
think that oh wait this is X so a times
W these are the individual margins and
so X of aw log is monotones by a play
law this is like log some X so it's
really looking like I have max margin
it's looking like I have maximum over
the margins but what's not in here is
that normalization so here's a quick
calculation so if I write down the
minimum margin and S naught T pointed
out I have to normalize it so this is my
definition of the minimum margin I look
over all the training points oh yeah
let's just say these are norm one at
most so here's the the definition of the
margin is just this l2 normalized
minimum over the output margins and i
just insert our log in an X and then I
just use definition of the risk and so
this is just log one over the risk okay
this is lower about it so if I can so
here's the intuitive proof okay here's
the proof idea so if I can just say
firstly that every time this goes up by
one this goes up by gamma the maximum
margin then and if I can show the NAM
denominator goes to infinity that I'm
done okay so I'm saying norms go to
infinity and for every unit of norm you
increase the numerator by gamma okay
Bassem tonically you just take an
integral or just think about them
accumulating the numerator is going to
be essentially gamma times the norm and
the bottoms gonna be norm okay here's
going to get gamma
everybody follow so that is the
intuition I want everyone at least to
leave this is the domain attrition want
everybody to leave with one perspective
is that gradient descent and the linear
case and yes you can correct this for
the homogeneous case for instance in a
natural way what gradient descent is
doing is for every unit of norm it's
getting one unit of margin and I think
this actually answers your question
whatever you want to do it's just
squeezing out everything in the other
directions there's no there's no room
there's nowhere to go okay so that's the
intuition numerator goes by gamma
denominator goes by one okay well we
still we still need to prove this but
yeah yeah I I can yes I can say a number
of things about other about other losses
but cryptically for now I'll just say
that you better have an exponential tail
there are actually some negative results
for that
the key the solution has to go to
infinity
baby but then we'd have to hedge really
carefully you know and well it depends
on I mean if we take a regulation path
and however I set it up I mean if the
loss is really close I mean there are
weird examples I can instruct just in
exponential at least in percolating the
transition metals to civilization the
loss in the interior it doesn't go to
infinity then we initialize in there all
I'm saying all I'm saying is that
yeah if what you're asking is whether
asymptotically we get to maximum
direction then exactly then yeah but I
was I was big baking in some epsilon
every so let's go through this really
quickly so here's so now I'm proving
this this gamma for each unit of norm
statement oh sorry I was gonna write it
on before I put it up but let me just
step through now that it's up let me
just step through this with all of you
let's look through the numerator terms
so I'm just starting from what I wrote
over here the lower bound on the margin
okay and I'm gonna just look at this in
terms of the derivative okay and then at
the end you integrate over this
so the okay it's log of the risk so take
the derivative chain rule I spit out one
over the risk times I chain rule one
more time derivative with respect with
respect to the parameters derivative the
crown respective time and by the
definition of gradient flow these are
just the negation of each other so I
just get the norm squared maybe well in
the denominator there's a couple ways to
see this but this is upper bounded by
this one way is to writing the square
root of the norm squared and the audio
de you know these cancel and I just end
up with with the norm of the gradient
divided by the risk
okay
and you know put the slides up this is
just so you stopped me in the street and
and you require more details this is the
proof I go through in my head and now
here's how we get that this is gamma so
let me just say that let me introduce
some more notation again so by chain
rule the gradient the gradient of this
thing is a transpose X okay so this is
my gradient and I'm just introducing
this notation where I pushed the R into
this term to normalize it okay so now I
get this normalized thing okay so I've
got that this thing is lower bounded by
this expression and I just have to show
this is gamma and here's one way to do
it I go back to 1962 or you know after
all the civilization collapse is the
next version of 962 and this is
literally copy paste from the Novikov
perceptron truth so I take them with the
gradient and this is a norm so the
variational form soup / unit vectors I
just write in the Mac a max my ginger
direction it turns out it's unique don't
need that here though so just take this
inner product expand things out and I'm
now I've just got only one vector that's
the data I rather this inner product and
by definition of X margin each one of
these does that leave gamma okay so
we're done with the first part so again
what we've said is that for every unit
of norm we increase the margin by at
least gamma a so for every new norm this
log 1 over risk increased by gamma if
the norm goes to infinity then we get
the max margin direction okay but you
know that's that's what's going on my
head here I look at this and I say every
time I increased by one I'm increasing
my margin by gamma and that's
okay because I'm going a little slow let
me just say that there are a couple ways
to prove that the weights go to infinity
maybe you can check check this later if
you wish and let me just say that you
you can show though that the weights in
general go like log T and this will
curse us a lot later so as Jason was
saying there are a lot of things that
happen in a sort of intermediate regime
this log T is so slow that it's it's
like asymptotic so again I'm only
talking about the linear case right now
but there are many of these things that
carry over for phrase deep settings and
the phenomena there will be will take
exponential time to reach okay do you
have a question or okay well it might be
good because it helped us regular eyes
right
you mean it suggests that we should
regular eyes is that what you're saying
or no might help us bad guys
Oh even if they're something really
weird that happens way off okay so yes
I'm writing this into a theorem as Jason
mentioned is a long time ago I gave you
the the gradient flow intuition
converting the gradient flow statement
into a gradient descent statement you
have to just prove a smoothness
inequality when you get almost this
everything the same you just proved a
slightly different smoothness inequality
for l1 and l2 for according to
centigrade ascent and the setting the
regime not he talked about where we're
not talking about just getting max
margin we're talking about the career
straight of the normalized predictor to
the actual unique direction we can
convert this in a state to a statement
of the above form with the same rate
just by Koshi schwartz and adding and
subtracting and stuff like that
okay
so here it is again 1 1 unit of margin
gamma is a margin for one unit of norm
let me just make a quick comment about
the non-separable case so one motivation
to study the separate linearly separable
data is you can say well once we beef up
this proof to the deeper lu case deeper
i'll use get zero training on everything
so everything is separable on the other
hand it might take forever to get a good
margin in that regime and while means
that we did analyze the non-separable
case i just want to say that if you go
back to the bounds like dan mentioned
all the all the bounds they look like
infimum over gamma of probability that
your predictor as a gamma margin
violation plus 1 over you know whatever
your complexity measure is over n so we
have this you know the infimum of in
this is not not in general gonna be
attained for making this term zero so
just an open problem all of these
results have talked about as far as I
know nobody on earth knows how to prove
a rage to get to some good margin for
most of the data ok I don't know how to
prove a good margin for 90% of the data
you try to adapt these proofs to that
you're in a world of hurt
you see this relevant for the deep um
well I think so let me let me say it
another way you were asking about maybe
we can make a generalization around the
sensitive the entire distribution of
margins so I tried to solve that problem
I got nowhere and I said well a simpler
one is just to control like different
slices to distribution and I got nowhere
on that too so I could so if you believe
you're a distribution version of the
problem then and I would say this is a
very miniature open problem towards that
okay let me give you the module version
I think they're versions of this really
study the rate at which the margin
distribution case yeah there are
assumptions we've got the whole
distribution sister tale and I also
don't know how to use those in this kind
of analysis okay yeah the story I wanted
you guys all to get was that for every
unit of norm I get gamma unit of margin
and that's why this works okay let me
tell you about a dual view let me
actually
pretty brief in this section except for
one one kind of old observation actually
so let me just summarize these slides
that's like glide through them one is if
we just write down the convex duality
notice that this is exactly the norm or
the gradient so this gives us a an even
more direct way to prove this gamma
lower bound I can say whatever this is
it's a it's it's lower bound invited by
the dual value okay so that's like a
don't even have to talk talk to no
Novikov through the through the ice ages
let me also say that if you write down a
regularize driscoll so come out and I
should say that so as Jason mentioned I
worked on this in grad school it was
actually this that caused me to learn
duality because I was studying the
exponential risk the new pmm didn't
exist all the convex optimization I do
is a member can the dual where they well
they're global Maximizer always exists
okay now let me draw you a little cute
picture same as before but I'm doing one
funny thing I'm scaling points by the
dual weight okay so I defined these dual
variables that are you notice the
elements of the of the loss
so did it make any sense it's it's
everything that you get without the
chain rule if these things the loss own
individual points okay so to say run
gradient descent and highlight points
according to that quantity you see it
concentrates a decision boundary so this
kind of gives a support vector view of
what's going on here the gradient is
dominated by those points closest to the
boundary so if you look at this thing
you know it's gonna be a convex
combination of or after normalized a
comic combination of data points and
it's focusing on the supporting points
okay so here's the here's the dual view
of the algorithm I want to give you so
here's the definition of gradient
descent where I've just expanded the
chain rule for you that's why it's plus
instead of minus and what I'm going to
do is I'm going to try to rewrite this
as an update in terms of these dual
variables just to be clear the dual
variables are
okay so I want to rewrite this in terms
of that I'm just gonna do basic algebra
to get there so first so I want it one
way to look at it I want to convert this
into this if they multiply by a I take
exponential of negation of both sides
and now I just use the definition
okay so I've rewritten this algorithm as
something totally in a dual variables
and I don't know about all of you but I
look at this and I see power method and
I'm very happy about this because we're
saying if the algorithm is finding
directions both in the primal and the
dual it's finding directions and finding
directions sounds like power method to
me so this this to me looks like power
method except you know what what is this
thing so it's a bizarro power method in
some weird geometry and this geometry
has a name this is just marry descent
with the KL divergence but what's cool
now is that before we were saying oh
kind of implicitly gradient descent is
finding my exponent directions when the
dual it's explicitly finding max margin
directions okay this is Mhairi descent
on the dual objective for the max margin
problem okay it's explicit max margin
and I should say that this this
connection is known it's known for 20
years so mad fur was given an
environment and then this was actually
used to give the first convergence proof
of of adaboost so Celeste we were
discussing the solutions of a debut
start if infiniti can't open a convex
optics book to reason about what it's
doing
the original convergence proofed used
something like this to gave no rates
this was used to prove the current
analysis on the risk on a risk not on
the margins on the risk
oh sure
so this objective in order to get the
max margin in order to get the Maximizer
to happen I'm gonna have to make an
assumption on the step size which is not
the adaboost step size let me just give
a let me just give a little more factoid
on top of what what Jason said if you
look back in the in the Atticus papers
they're actually constructions data sets
for which it does not find the max
margin so that's not just like a upper
bound artifact it's real
okay so here's actually the thing with
constant step size so if you translate
this into the boosting setting it's not
what they use so we can get something
interesting here which is that these
norm of gradients these actually form a
monotone sequence okay so this thing is
like your observed margin is always
shrinking
okay and just as promised I was gonna
make a I was gonna make a comment on
this proof by surgery at all or it's
like rude right so three of you are here
so this just gives a convergence rate in
the dual it doesn't say anything about
converging to the max margin direction
even if this is with the right step size
with some work you can get a convergence
rate from here in the primal so you can
do this this two-step proof step one for
instant individual step to convert it
into a result about the primal and while
it's not the same proof when I look at
your guys's proof I see all the same
steps but just in a different order and
package it two differently strange map
space permutation okay in the remaining
miniscule amount of time let me just
tell so yeah the key thing I wanted you
to get from this talk were were two
perspectives that give you margin
maximization one was this for every unit
of distance you go one unit of margin
perspective where the units are like
scale by gamma and the other is this
dual view where we're doing explicit
margin maximization in okay let me just
give some nonlinear comments one is so
in a deep linear case which has come up
three times now here's the theorem you
can prove and I'll just I want to tell
you I send the dog this here you talked
about this yesterday I know that he's
very excited about the conditions on the
theorem so let me just read them off for
you
this assumes separate bility and an
additional assumption about the support
vectors that can be dropped so please
just treat that as technical I'm just
being careful to include that my risk is
no worse than the zero vector and I'm
not at a stationary point I don't start
at a at a saddle or something it's a
gradient to do something so if you do
either gradient flow where it's some
gradient descent with a small step size
on this
then as Jason mentioned this happens
okay this is all cases where the Jason
said all I'm doing here is I'm writing
it in a different way and that's why I
do not get the two over l it's it's what
he had on the right hand side
I want to make a different comment about
this so if you dissect if you dissect
what this means because the solution is
just a rank one thing all the matrices
align they have all this nice
cancellation so this this WL w1 these
all become rank rank one matrices
rank one matrices where all the inner
terms are the same so this next one ul
minus 1 these are the same and this last
one is the max margin predictor it's
like very nice structure and all I'll
say is that if you if you could read
this into a Oh X ray I was gonna also
say that for deeper Lu I was gonna make
some comments but Jason made better ones
so just go back in time one cool thing
you can do from this perspective is one
way to plot this alignment property is
this alignment that I mentioned here
implies that you're actually solving a
maximization problem at every layer ok
so I was excited about this because it
gave me some understanding of what
happens internally intermediate layers
so people if you map the data forward so
that's this is the input data I said
that the first layer at solving a
maximization problem if you look at the
next layer map the data through the
first layer and you see what's happening
here you again solve a max margin
problem so kind of all the suffixes of
the network are solving max margin
problems on the prefixes of the network
cool cool thing that you know so don't
I'm saying don't underestimate what what
this means this actually has kind of
amazing structure inside of it ok so
just to summarize the main thing I of
course got kind of ahead of myself as
always but the main thing I wanted
everyone to extract from from the talk
today other than the usual margin
propaganda is that the max margin
phenomenon is kind of very reliable and
there's a there's two simple intuitions
for it one simple intuition is that or
sorry that word is a band I think Jason
said can't use the word okay there are
two intuitions for one intuition is that
for every unit of norm I get one gamma
unit of margin that's the primal
intuition and the dual intuition is that
it's an explicit max margin solver in
the dual
[Applause]
okay okay so that's gone great fall
service
[Applause]